[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans le spectre vous a senti
un petit peu une bientôt cocktail vous
sera sam sa passion notamment je
voudrais évoquer avec vous le tandem des
encombrements ultime les connaissez tous
certainement mais suivi c'est toujours
le soir de leur part la journée papeete
fortement au dîner bien calé quelle
était la solution proposée par les
autorités publiques de quelques années
et bien des routes toujours plus la
route et un son toujours aussi auront
vous pouvez dire sur trois la vitesse à
laquelle on roule à 7,9 km les uns à
gauche vous avez l'art ou un peu aux
touristes se l'imaginent alors est ce
que nous ne voulons simplifier la mince
bande côtière que nous avons à tahiti
mais fragile cette bande côtière
est ce que vous voulez le raid américain
au dessus de nankin des anglais à tout
l'espace mis leur m de la réunion
peu d'entre vous le savent il ya une
grogne est construite en plein océan à
15 milliards de francs pacifique le kilo
c'est une autre sono alors je pense
qu'il faut se placer dans une
perspective à louvain la seconde est
arrivée en 1959 c'était pas très grand
en matto un mois deux mois actuellement
pour faire part ne pas péter 20h par la
voie des airs en 59 me suis rendu en
gambie dix journées
actuellement vous mettez deux trois
heures voilà en un désert
pourquoi ne pas penser pour une zone
urbaine a passé en l'air le moment de
vous envoyer en l air en centre ne
distingue pas ce que c'est et bien c'est
un produit qui est c'est une idée qui
m'est venue en 2011
on est dans une chronique radio qui
évoquait déjà existantes transporte
partout en amérique du sud
alors j'ai quelquefois des idées comme
ça certaines routines autres non celle
là ça ne les a pas un gros morceau mais
sont poursuivis notamment pour l'abattre
parce qu'on a choisi le doublement tan
social catastrophique
vous allez la pollution par les gaz
d'échappement la pollution des sols
peu le savent pas les freinages les
particules au freinage qui mena et
lumière et qui a mobilisé dans le sas a
conduit à des maladies cardiaques 3 mais
aussi les accidents de la route lui si
vous avez également la fatigue stress dû
à la conduite dans les embouteillages
le manque de sommeil vous avez une vraie
catastrophe écologique
ensuite est-ce que le dégagement dessous
de participation allègrement ici à
tahiti participation au réchauffement
climatique
à l'odéon aux morts ce décor et les
imprimantes
ensuite vous avez des dépenses des
dépenses financières importantes pour
les ménages ces statistiques ont à mon
sens le budget est consacré c'est
considérable et ce qui fait que ça
aggrave les inégalités sociales des
personnes par pays - qu'est-ce qui a
d'autres comme problème des déchets eau
déchets des huiles usagées
vous avez tous les carcasses couverture
on enlèvera les pneus et matri qui
plombe la halle aux énormes et c'est
donc j'avais un vrai désastre sanitaire
écologique et même sociale et ça je
crois pas assez le monde ensemble
alors peut-on faire et bien l'idée mais
c'est un iphone c'est quoi c'est ça fait
référence outre à l'emblématique et il
est au ciel
donc pourquoi ne pas passer par la voie
des airs
dans notre pays ça s'appelle le métro
quand on est payé d'allemagne fut le
tram aérien
on m'a même utiliser et lérys
téléphérique
tout ça c'est des systèmes qui
fonctionnent avec un transport alors
pour donner un petit peu d une idée de
ce que c'est bon vous avez à se faire ou
bien des gars en haut à gauche
vous avez une gare est située dans l'île
de madère c'est en bord de mer
revenu au sénégal il ya aucun souci pour
le scar x 100 m sabathia qui m'allume y
de chaud ça là c'est un média tu es bien
intégré dans son environnement dans un
par un à gauche à droite parce que vous
avez également une image du jour à
madère d'un binôme et de cabines avec
une mannequin en bas à droite
une autre photo de type de gars qui est
situé à barcelone
on voit les gamines alors les cabines de
capacités sous son ascèse de personnes
les portes s'ouvrent automatiquement et
en dessous automatiquement les personnes
à mobilité réduite et des prix mais
[Musique]
voilà nous miner un peu le lieu le matin
et var des pilotes des cabines des
images s'il y a à bochum a une semaine
pour être le scan preuve qu'ils
passeraient dans sa structure proche des
plus ou moins lointain le long du futur
plus ou moins proche et lointain mine à
issia alors comment ça fonctionne il y a
vous avez un unique moteur électrique
qui entraîne un tas faire plusieurs
kilomètres sur ce cas ne sont approchés
des timings à l'arrivée au lard les
canines sont décrochés et elles sont
allées ce qui permet le démarque depuis
l'embarquement des passagers et à la
sortie de le
la famille devrait approcher sur le tas
appels système les canidés braille à
l'intérieur six tables c'est qu'on a un
tapis toujours à la même vitesse donc
vous fait énormément décliné et n'a
point fondamental alors l'énergie bien
sûr essayer d'être le plus vert possible
dans ce verte
donc on peut équiper les télécabines
panneaux photovoltaïques également les
gars alors ce système vous disais on dit
c'est mon père murphy dans les années
2000 début des années 2000 maintenant on
a de nombreuses lignes dans des villes
comme maintenir la base il ya bientôt
dix minutes 4 merci qu'au sein de miley
un projet qui lançait de construire donc
ces systèmes journée on a même des
tendances menant à se développer partout
dans le monde et donc même en métropole
en france et même à l'outre-mer quelques
images pour me mener un projet fiscal
dont la gauche nommé une gare qui existe
à lisbonne donc qui ressemble au dessus
même d'une un fleuve ensuite en
ressentent
vous avez une photo d'une nouvelle gare
qui n'est pas coté mexico qui est au
dessus des barres entière omaha à droite
également à ankara en turquie au dessus
des mois entiers donc si vous voulez là
les gars peuvent s'adapter à leur
environnement urbain garde donc il ya
une adaptation aussi
ensuite au niveau de l'esthétique
esthetic peut être adapté aussi à
l'environnement au pays sa culture donc
un exemple on la droite avait
lynas mona ou trois pilotes terminent
c'est à portland usa ont mal au genou il
esquisse du premier projet déjà acté à
la réunion qu'ils ont commencé à
s'occuper de ce genre de problème ne
sera pas rattrapé donc un projet qui est
acté l'ouverture nos minimes a donc levé
stick pointe son nez particulièrement
apte et qui pourrait imaginer pourquoi
pas des cabines qui rappellerait une
trappe ou des pilotes sera fait ou alors
tu as tout est envoyé des références
ensuite de haut niveau des lignes
ennemies donc créé et bien en 2013 nous
avons fait venir à l'expert et nous
avons défini deux mois les ebook est il
partirait en euros du canda rouler et
qui régissent le dv2 phare une deuxième
ligne qui partirait donc qui permit en
eau et qu'il irait jusqu'au dépôt
d'armes des faits les kilomètres à cela
on a proposé également de lignes
complémentaires ligne i am attirer les
touristes arrivent en force sur la ligne
principale est également une ligne qui
desservirait
par exemple pour donner un exemple
télésérie aînés en contact on est donc
maintenant se le faire dire plat et donc
on avait proposé une calme en desserte
de la zone résidentielle de poids et on
a fait également sa une pour le même
veine m imaginez aussi développer la
route à faire les activités de loisirs
et d'hébergement en d'affaires
j'aimais le dire que montceau les mines
principal vous avez à peu près des gares
ou les 700 alors le principe même il ya
très peu d'occupation soit néanmois le
tracé est soigneusement étudié pour
permettre de face et de survoler
uniquement des terrains publics la
majeure partie de ces également des
voies routières également pour
l'installation des gars dans des
domaines publics
il évoque alors nous allons barrer dans
notre petite cabine n'avons pas attendu
parce qu'il ya un flux continu de
également nous n'avons pas l'aura
respectives ça peut fonctionner 19
heures par nuit sans problème c'est ce
qui se passe
nous avons un temps de parcours
constants bien sûr ce qui a pas
d'interaction avec le sol vous êtes sûr
donnant un exemple vous avez un système
camp ferrat channels à l'université où
elle allait passer la poutre la place
to'ata eh bien vous les frais d'un
milieu à 17 kilomètres à parcourir
si tu leur exemple panda roux et jusqu'à
la maison d'un coup pour m assurer et
puis vous n'avez pas de problème de
stationnement à l'arrivée alors nous
attendre dans votre cabine et bien vous
êtes
ces 20 m eur très peu de bruit c'est
confortable agréable si vous avez la vue
sur la mer sur le métal ça peut être
convivial puisque on verra dans les
cabines sont conçus les deux banquettes
qui se passe donc je trouve enfin des
gens c'est de moi tous les matins tout
seul mot convivialité et aussi brassage
social
il y en a besoin de moi social brassage
aussi intergénérationnel dans une cabine
d'un côté vous aurez peut-être pu voir
ou un chat avec sa vie secrète qui va
dans la même dynamique satisfaites nous
a déplacé en parfaite sécurité même dans
la ville de manning est resté près de
grasse où l'arrivée enfin dans la gare
de destination la gare peut être équipé
de boutiques
le service public le parti mais prendre
une interconnexion les débuts seraient
interconnectés et ce système là le
transport très interactifs dans le monde
ma musique géniale pour les hommes même
voie
ensuite nous à les rendre une simone
système est efficace en 7200 personnes
par heure peuvent circuler sur toute
cette importance à permettre une
décongestion des paris dont un système
efficace et arty
il y a que 6 % des déplacements se font
en russe s'est très est-ce que c'est pas
alors l'avenir incertain à sa
destination simpara cher compliqué alors
en termes de coûts d'investissement on
est à deux fois moins cher par ce
système le bus en site propre ni avec
des voix a réservé bien séparés des
autres devant vous avez très peu
d'exportations s'attire la forme d une
durée de construction extrêmement rapide
de l'orval a mise en ligne ce que vous
n'avez pas à déterrer une égalisation
qui sont en solde étant interviennent
près fiable et de monuments en termes de
coûts de fonctionnement eh bien on est
quatre fois moins chère qu'un système
avec lui pour transporter une personne
sur 1 km ça prouve à peu près - 2
c'est maintenant à quoi sert obtient
donc un système économique en
fonctionnement
ça c'est très important beaucoup de
qualité en france va les voir alors et
l'écolo jean environnement s'établit
bien anodin d'échappement pannecé onu
peu de déchet et 10 une consommation
énergétique quatre fois moins un système
de bus équivalente on se prend ça c'est
très important à leurs défis climatiques
et de son urgence
voilà un système qui au delà moussa
pouey donner une image différente de
tahiti
une image à la fois de modernité mais
aussi de références picturales
on peut adapter designed effectivement
la culture quotidienne également est un
symbole fort de développement bras du
choix partie d'un des bars vous voilà
alors ce projet peut se réaliser
il suffit que les pony détiennent le vin
et le soutien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]